in brussels happiness among eu leaders
and possibly a dash of well-hidden
relief
after almost a month of debate
breakthrough on plans to sanction
russian oil
we started with coal yesterday in the
middle of the night we decided then to
have a ban now on de facto 90 of russian
oil
imports to the european union by the end
of the year
perhaps this man hungary's prime
minister has the most to celebrate
in a video message victor orban
delighted russian oil would keep flowing
into his country after his resolute
refusal to cut off a main pipeline
helped ensure sanctions were watered
down
only oil delivered by sea is going to be
banned initially and while the package
also targets key individuals three state
broadcasters and removes russia's
biggest bank from the swift system it's
still a weaker version than the original
presidents are you disappointed that the
oil deal was diluted if they were they
weren't showing it
compromise better than failure are you
frustrated by hungary
and this is why the oil ban is so
important as the biggest buyer of
russian crude europe has been pouring
cash into putin's pockets now they're
cutting off billions of dollars of
funding for his war
the polish prime minister one of those
keen to hit the kremlin where it hurts
this is why poland is one of the most
you know radical proponents of crushing
sanctions
uh the quicker the better the more
the harsher the better
can the world ever be safe while
president putin holds power in russia
if
europe and the free world
loses this battle loses this war
we are not going to be safe
any longer round the corner from the
leaders meeting another gathering
here ukrainian refugees grateful for
support but frustrated by delays
europe is quite too late with with the
decisions that every day women and
children are dying
and russian oil
is the cause because european money
are paying
for ukrainian death
for now ukrainians have no choice but to
wait
hoping the next set of sanctions
will finally help stop putin's war
machine in its tracks siobhan robbins
sky news brussels